good try you have to bifurcated did she
deserve the honor probably not is she
Brave of course she's Brave all those
years invested is is okay this was the
beginning I remember this so clearly I
remember being 18 okay and this whole
thing happened it was like I just
remember I was a freshman in college and
I remember thinking like ah this is
weird but I was kind of in my own world
so I just didn't really care but in
hindsight I should have been so vocal
about this because this was the at the
beginning of the end of women's sports
which they're doing now guys I just did
a volleyball tournament this weekend
with a bunch of trans people in it a
bunt there was like almost a whole team
full